hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and tonight
I went and saw the Grinch the Grinch a
very 2018 Grinch miss I'm one of the
people who is in the camp of actually
really liking the Jim Carrey Grinch I
know that the people don't agree don't
watch this Doug Walker I really like it
I grew up with it I thought it was funny
it's I mean miles and miles and miles in
worlds and worlds and world above Cat in
the Hat
live-action though of course I mean not
of course have your own opinions for me
the the originalist
a lot better I still really enjoy the
Grinch one I think it's funny and I
think the sexual stuff kind of went over
my head as a kid so that didn't really
bother me I just rewashed it recently
and would have to agree that I don't
know I think that any any kind of sex
jokes in the Grinch just don't really
belong I could see what they were trying
to do with incorporating them but I
don't think it really worked
this thankfully no sex jokes amazing
great brilliant just what we asked for
first thing I'll say is that I really
enjoyed this movie I thought it was
extremely cute and adorable and I teared
up at the end and the voice acting was
marvelous and brilliant and I think it
was a nice retelling of it it was very
well adapted for kind of the time that
we live in in 2018 I liked it though I
do think it took a little bit away from
the character of the Grinch but that
doesn't mean that I didn't like it it
just means that it's kind of different
from who the character is overall I
think the story itself is really cute
it's a great kind of retelling of the
story that we already know with a few
more additions to it he runs out of food
at the very beginning so he has to go
down the hill when Christmas is starting
in December and go stock up on food and
then he finds out that Christmas is
gonna be three times bigger than ever
due to the mayor wanting it to be bigger
and then he sees the tree that they
brought in and then he's like I must
ruined Christmas and goes on this whole
adventure to get the sleigh in this
whole thing
reindeer and then the whole night of him
taking all the presents and then you get
him learning his beautiful wonderful
lesson we all have seen a million times
with the Grinch I think the biggest
difference for me is at least I didn't
feel this way I don't think in the
original and definitely not in the Jim
Carrey one is that I felt so sad for him
the whole time he never really felt like
a villain he just felt like I'm kind of
just not understood really sad lonely
guy and I guess you could fight that
that's what he was in the original but
it's played up a lot more in this in the
original and the Jim Carrey it's toyed
around with that he is kind but it's
underneath all of this terrible exterior
and this is like no he's very very kind
just sometimes you get scratchy it's so
it's kind of a big switch now I'm the
Grinch
I think the animation is really
beautiful really cute
I think Whoville is great as it is in
all of the renditions of this I would
say I really enjoy the change to
cindy-lou who she is like this badass
like hockey player who loves to sled and
has a secret hang out with your best
friend and she's planning on capturing
Santa on Christmas Eve so that she can
ask him for a very special present which
is she wants her mom to be happy it's
her mom seemingly is a single mother who
works the night shift at a hospital and
then takes care of the kids all day and
she can tell that it's stressing her out
and she just wants tanta to help that
that's returns the Grinch around is he's
there he gets captured by her on
Christmas Eve it's the last house that
he has to steal all the presents from
and he's like I know what you want you
just want presents and she's saying I
don't want presents I just want this for
my mom and it really changes him and
then the reindeer that he got helps him
out and then he's over he's turned to
use a better man and he'll never Grinch
Grinch myths again courage courage it's
really sweet it was all just like a
little too easy it felt like there's
something to be said for going in
you a movie where you already know
exactly what's gonna happen it's like
seeing a Christmas Carol or something
but it felt just like a little too easy
like I knew it was all gonna happen I
kind of Ike I'm trying to film over here
he doesn't mean care you show a little
remorse hike hike hike
hi I'm gonna skin you alive yes I will
may be clearly max is the best part of
any Grinch story and he was in this max
and the Grinch have a lot better of a
relationship in this which again it's
kind of going against the Grinch's
character but it's like you be fun to
watch I the Grinch was nicer to max in
this film that I am being too Ike right
now so that's saying something
I wrote it feels more grounded and I
don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing
it felt less magical it felt like you
could really really identify with these
characters where I would say and the Jim
Carrey one you really can't like it's
very fanciful and at different it's a
different beast this felt a lot more
grounded and I like that but I also like
the the fancifulness of the Grinch so I
don't know I can't really tell if I
liked it because of that or if I liked
it for for other things or if like it
would have been better is like just
another movie or what's happening I
thought the voice acting was excellent
Kenan Thompson plays the funniest
character in this movie I thought his
especially his voice acting was so well
done so funny such a great character
really cute and I wish that he would
have been in it 10 times more and he was
in it a pretty good amount but damn damn
I loved him Benedict Cumberbatch that
his name I'm not even trying to make a
joke that's his name right I don't know
he was really good and again less angry
and more cutesy I mean he doesn't really
have a cutesy voice but it was less
scary monster and more just uh I'm just
a regular guy what's up I'm the Grinch I
wrote I cried at the end it's got to be
a really bad Christmas movie for me now
to cry at the end though so I don't
think that's saying that much overall I
would definitely recommend this movie I
think it's really cute there were a ton
of kids in my my theater and this has
been out for like two weeks now right or
three weeks I hope it's doing well it
didn't thrill me but it also didn't bore
me or make me sad or upset at all
thought it was really cute
really well done definitely not
life-changing but it's a good enough
movie it's really sweet
don't imagine that's what any filmmaker
is going for that's a good enough movie
but it's better than what could be what
the alternative could be well it's the
next Birdemic so can you imagine if this
was the next Birdemic if somehow the
animated Grinch the next terrible the
room that's a great image I know it took
me a long time to see this but I'm glad
that I did thank you for asking on
Twitter tell me what you want me to see
every week for Tamara just saw and I
will do my darndest to get it done thank
you so much for watching see you next
week bye oh wait I wrote Loki very
excited for ugly bill also holy hell
spies in the skies yes Will Smith yes
yes Tom Holland yes all right now by
your mean one mr. Grinch oh yeah that
song wasn't in it that's kind of weird
huh okay bye you've got garlic in your
soul mr. Grinch
[Music]